welcome to this video on playing he
would he had 45 I would have bet that
I've played him before but the
statistics draw the statistics of draw a
blank never played him it seems ok so
I'm a stone wall which is not to
advisable really in this in this person
specific move order yeah maybe castles
it's just the case that here why does
much more comfortable in comparison to
to the normal stone war was g3 being
played on g3 it is in fact not so well
placed the the bishop this is so much
more much more comfortable
okay maybe just grab the space yeah yeah
it takes a very specific type of person
to to defend this position as black it
seems a very very yeah it seems like a
very painful task to me but there are
there are take us to to do this
strangely enough okay queena three but
should be two wins the Queen so this is
not happening I came still it wins the
Queen I want to get the night to d3 she
cannot take it again I guess okay I need
to move this anyway on the way to d3 so
I might as well protect this ok g5
really that's the reason why i wanted to
do i go to do to d3 it also protects a
form ok now let's go for kingi to rook
h1h form maybe maybe i should have
played the ant actor should have done
that i should have played the King f2 ok
this is still ok not a problem at all
h4 takes root take this Queen age from
so I need to really go King King f2
first and only then aged from covering
deform
okay so it's trying to get to some
counter play on the queenside now the
night is very strong on d3 it even
protects the b2 entry square oh wait
takes rook takes rook g3 maybe this was
a possibility really hmm maybe okay
anyway now the King side is closed and
the attention should be switched to the
to the Queen side should i play
95 not sure but it's maybe a cone for
concrete reason its reasons it's maybe a
good move Jake's pawn takes the screen
h6 mate threatened so the Queen cannot
really go to a good square two must go
to g7 or g6 otherwise create six
checkmate okay and here I can also just
take a onesie for F takes Bishop d3 is
very nice but I'm not I'm not totally
sure maybe just keep this blocked for
the moment not one hundred percent sure
what's the right right set up yeah the
nice thing is that even though if we
just trade everything down to a bishop
end game even this will be very
problematic for black I'm being being a
bit cautious cm in my evaluation maybe
it is a winning endgame okay Bishop p.m.
yeah if I take you still cannot you can
take with the Queen maybe but then
looking at form okay i do that okay
simply this one tying the Queen to h5 or
that forcing is forcing this trade okay
so how much to do this now maybe first
this one always useful no ask black and
what's your next move okay
I always have air outside of duty 5 at
the right moment I'm okay there should
be seven how does how does he protects
you six I guess it doesn't I with this i
will look this i simply overlook this
but okay it's not any problem here i can
at least them time warning try to double
on the beef i'll look g8 bishop a six
should be good for me as rupees 7s
always threatening at the end to to pin
the bishop let's let's just cover this
first g4
be some yeah 11 rook traded is really
used for him I know I could have taken
but I just prefer to control everything
here it's a this is do not hurry
situation okay well now that's
absolutely no reason not to take it
check yeah the SEC could have played
somewhat somewhat easier check hmm how
do I win this actually check
I know I'm down yet time unbelievable
and he's got her the bigger leg in in
addition check check check black for
fits on time yeah I came this wasn't too
convincing the last ten or twelve oaks
a4 was stupid a for most especially
stupid here if a four is just a very
stupid move does not does not help at
all um yeah it was really weird what I
would I did I mean wrong ok this is this
wasn't the beginning here I just need to
be more precise cannot enter here I just
had an ok just rupee ATM and then and
then attack the pawns from behind yeah
this is winning very easily in fact yeah
I wonder what I underestimated here in
the in the limited time is that he has
this checks okay it's still plus three
for the comp but it was somewhat
somewhat uncomfortable okay and the
computer wants to play just this yeah
maybe this is the easiest it feels a bit
weird to draw 2-2 read withdraw
everything to the first rank but yeah I
always have a hard time to understand
how how anyone could could deliberately
went go for this type of position this
is just medical medic ISM method
Chisholm whatever yeah for people who
enjoy getting tortured because I one
unless the opponent is blundering the
queen or anything how are you ever going
to win a game just just totally without
any any sort of active
idea yeah I don't know very very
one-sided stuff yeah yeah that's
multiple ideas even there is even if you
if everything else fails you can play
this and the kid this is totally blocked
and next Queen a3 rugby three rugby one
maybe maybe this is the easiest of all
that I wanted to have to still the
option to attack a weakness on the King
side and this is obviously more
favorable as h5 as weak and all the time
you have this terrible bishop here yeah
here Ruby 7s ourselves very strong will
lose pawns yeah as I really feel that
this is this kind of position s is so so
prospectus the regular stone wall
against g3 is a different matter this is
not so so much of a problem hit like
that black has some many more
possibilities to play actively here it's
very tough alright thanks for watching